. This is really great.
When Barack Obama was president, Fox News
said that executive orders were tyranny.
They were tyrannical.
When Trump became president, FOX News said
Trump's executive orders are fine because
he has to undo the tyranny that were Barack
Obama's executive orders.
And now on day one, Joe Biden signed 17 executive
orders, undoing some of the worst of the worst
of what Donald Trump did.
And once again, Fox News host Ainsley Earhardt.
Her feelings are hurt.
It is wild how everybody's feelings are now
the most important thing on Fox News.
And she doesn't think Joe Biden is acting
to unite America because undoing Trump's executive
orders with his own is mean guys.
These people are so childish and pathetic
and predictable.
Take a look at this.
Our country has got to come together.
And Joe Biden said yesterday, I want unity.
He talked about that in a speech.
But the first thing he does, the first order
of business is to walk in, sit down at the
table.
And he has 17 executive orders, really wiping
away much of what President Trump did.
So his supporters are saying, how can we have
unity if you're taking away everything that
we like, this is so stupid that it doesn't
even count as as political analysis.
The things Joe Biden dealt with yesterday
on day one, which I'm thrilled to have seen
him deal with, we're not just canceling counterproductive
things that Donald Trump did.
They were things that divided us from the
world.
If you want to talk about unity, everybody's
in the Paris climate accord.
We're out.
That's divisive.
Other countries are taking covid seriously.
But we have a president saying it's the flu
and it'll go away like a miracle in 15 cases
will be zero.
That's divisive in terms of the United States
from the rest of the world.
We are going to have four solid years of these
people whining that Joe Biden simply isn't
continuing everything Trump did.
If you follow what Ainsley Earhardt is saying
to its logical conclusion, anything that Joe
Biden does differently than Trump is apparently
not unity.
And that's right.
Joe Biden is not Trump.
These are the same people who for four years
under Trump said elections have consequences
and you lefties have to deal with it.
And they were right during the Trump era.
I agreed elections have consequences.
And that's why it was tragic that so many
leftists stayed home in 2016.
But the 2012 election also has consequences
and we're seeing them now.
And by the way, if Ainslee is correct and
on day one, Joe Biden really did undo everything
Donald Trump did, that confirms Trump didn't
do very much.
If Joe Biden in four hours, these were signed
within four hours of Joe Biden being sworn
in.
If in four hours, Biden can undo four years
worth of what Donald Trump did, Donald Trump
didn't do very much.
And we are going to just prepare yourselves.
This is what Fox News or worse, this is what
Fox News is going to look like for the next
four years.
Let me know your reaction and your feedback
to the early days of the Biden administration.
I'm on Twitter
at
David
Pakman